AT THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE. ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
IT ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCE
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE OR IS FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. 877-226-8163 AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO. EIGHT THREE THREE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE WEBSITE WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY MONTEREY
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND ZERO
FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRESS THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND
WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR
TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER IF
THIS CAN BE A SHORT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE. THE NUMBER YOU WILL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME. YOU WILL
BE AND MUTED AND YOU WILL BE
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US
TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
TODAY WE HAVE THREE BILLS ON THE
AGENDA. FOR THAT WE HEAR THE
BILL'S LET'S ESTABLISH QUORUM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. LIMON HERE LIMÓN HERE A CHIRLA
BUG. BRADFORD BRADFORD HERE
CABALLERO CABALLERO HERE DALLI
DALLI HERE THERE ALSO TORONTO
HERE WESO. HERE SO HERE. MAN MAN
PRESENT FORTINO PORTANTINO HERE
IF. YOU HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU
THE CONSULTANT NOTES A QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED BEFORE WE
HEAR FROM AUTHORS WE HAVE SB
TWELVE OH TWO ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DO WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR BRADFORD AT THE MOTION
AT TO ADOPT THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS MADE BY SENATOR BRADFORD
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE-
LIMON. I ALONE I A SHOWBOAT.
CONSENT. HI JOE BOAKAI BRADFORD. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I'LL BE
OUT HI DALLI DALLI I THEY'RE
ALSO. RASO HI WESO WHAT'S SO
FIVE MEN. MAN I PORTANTINO. I
DON'T KNOW. ME OR DEL I. NINE
ZERO. THE MOTION TO ADOPT THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS NINE VOTES
. AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO HEAR
FROM THE FIRST AUTHOR. OF THE
FIRST AUTHOR IS SENATOR DO TO US
SO YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR. BUT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
STAND UP WITH THANK THE CHAIR IN
THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL YOUR TIME
ON THIS BILL I ACCEPT THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON
PAGES SEVEN AND EIGHT OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT THE COLLECTION OF
RENT THAT IS COVERED BY THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS AS OTHER KINDS OF
CONSUMER DEBT UNDER THE STATE'S
ROSENTHAL FAIR DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES ACT SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL ADDS TO THE DEFICIT ADDS TO
THE DEFINITION OF CONSUMER. ANY
RENTAL THAT. BECAME PAST DUE ON
OR AFTER JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
NINETEEN. AND DEFINES RENTAL
THAT AS UNPAID RENT OR ANY OTHER
UNPAID FINANCIAL OBLIGATION OF A
TENANT UNDER TENDENCY. DURING
THE EVICTION MORATORIUM TENANTS
HAVE ACCUMULATED UNPRECEDENTED
pOF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER
FAMILY. THE RULES AND PROCESSES
FOR EVICTIONS PANDEMIC THAT AND
WRITTEN RELIEF HAVE BECOME
COMPLEX AND ARE CONSTANTLY
CHANGING MANY LANDLORDS HAVE
RECEIVED ASSISTANCE FROM RATE
RELIEF PROGRAMS AND IT'S
CRITICAL FOR FAMILIES TO
UNDERSTAND HOW MUCH DEBT THEY'VE
ACCUMULATED WHICH DEBTS ARE
STILL OUTSTANDING. AND THE
STATUS OF PAST DUE RENT PAID
THROUGH RENT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM-
JUST ON THE LAST DAY OF THE
STATEWIDE PROGRAM OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS WERE
SUBMITTED AND NEARLY OVER HALF A
MILLION APPLICATIONS WERE
SUBMITTED STATEWIDE. TENANTS
MUST HAVE ACCURATE INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR DEBT NOW THAT RELIEF
PROGRAMS HAVE ENDED AND WE ARE
BEGINNING TO NAVIGATE A
DIFFICULT LEGAL AND LANDSCAPE I
ECONOMIC LANDSCAPE TRANSPARENCY
IS EVEN MORE IMPORTANT. MY
DISTRICT NEARLY 80% ARE RENTERS
MANY OF THEM- LIKE MANY OF THE
FAMILIES IN YOUR DISTRICTS WERE
ALREADY LIVING ON THE EDGE
BEFORE THE DEEP INSTABILITY OF
THIS PANDEMIC. THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTES- MORTGAGE DEBT IS
ALREADY EXPRESSLY COVERED BY THE
ROSENTHAL ACT A PERSON OWES
RENTAL DEBT SHOULD ABSOLUTELY
ENJOY SIMILAR PROTECTIONS AS A
PERSON WHO OWES MORTGAGE DEBT.
HOMEOWNERS AND RENTERS HAVE BOTH
SUFFERED IN THIS CRISIS BOTH
DESERVE THE DIGNITY OF THESE
PROTECTIONS. SOME DAVID CHIU
MORATORIUM WAS MEANT TO KEEP
FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES WHILE
THE ACCESS NEEDED ASSISTANCE TO
KEEP OUR COMMUNITY STABLE AS WE
ATTEMPTED TO RECOVER AND HEAL
FROM A CRISIS THAT IS
PERMANENTLY CHANGED OUR WAY OF
LIFE WE MUST NOW HELP
CALIFORNIANS AS THEY WORK HARD
TO BUILD THEIR LIVES TODAY I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES HERE WITH US
TED MERMAN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
LOW INCOME CONSUMER COALITION
AND DANNY KENDALL **** ON BEHALF
OF A STINT. ATTENDANT TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT. JERRY BROWN MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING I'M TED MERMAN FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME
CONSUMER COALITION. SENATOR RAZA
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- MOVING
REMARKS THIS MORNING YOU YOU'VE
JUSTIFIED EXACTLY WHY THIS BILL
IS SO NECESSARY WE ARE FACED
TODAY WITH AN UNPRECEDENTED
SITUATION WE HAVE NEVER HAD IN
CALIFORNIA ANYTHING LIKE THE
BACKUP OF BACK RENT DEBT THAT
MILLIONS OF TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS NOW FACE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE PANDEMIC AND THE
VIXEN MORATORIUM HAVE LED TO
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS EVEN
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE SUBJECT TO DEBT
COLLECTION FOR THE FIRST TIME
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA NEED
THE LEGISLATURE TO DO SOMETHING
YOU PROBABLY HAVE DONE LONG
WHICH IS TO EXTEND THE
PROTECTIONS OF THE ROSENTHAL
ACT. TO COVER THE COLLECTION A
RENTAL THAT IT'S A QUIRK OF
DRAFTING THAT THIS STATE LAW
DOESN'T ALREADY EXPRESSLY APPLY
TO RENTAL THAT WHAT THE FEDERAL
FAIR DEBT COLLECTION PRACTICES
ACT DOES THIS IS A LOOPHOLE WE
CAN CLOSE NOW. TENANTS NEED
DESERVE THE SAME PROTECTIONS AS
OTHER DEBTORS THEY DESERVE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHO IS TRYING
TO COLLECT THE DEBT. THEY
DESERVE A BAN ON TELEPHONE CALLS
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT OR
THREATS TO THROW THEM IN JAIL IF
THEY DON'T PAY. AND THEY DESERVE
AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO ENFORCE
THOSE RULES. MEANWHILE LET BIRDS
NEED THE SAME RULES OF THE ROAD
AS OTHER BUSINESSES THAT ARE
COLLECTING THEIR DEBTS. ALMOST
ANY OTHER BUSINESS THAT A
CONSUMER OWES MONEY TO IN THE
STATE CAN CONSULT THE ROSENTHAL
ACT. THE SEE WHAT THEY CAN AND
CAN'T DO THE COLLECTED THAT FOR
LANDLORDS IT'S NOT CLEAR. THEY
DESERVE THE SAME CLARITY THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS PROVIDED
OTHER BUSINESSES. THE SPONSORS
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION ARE IN
SOLID AGREEMENT THE HARASSMENT
OF TENANTS SHOULD NEVER BE
ALLOWED WE ALSO AGREE THAT THERE
NEEDS TO BE A WAY TO ENFORCE THE
LAW AND WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN
A CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW BEST TO ACCOMPLISH
THESE GOALS THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS TWO OF THE
THREE ISSUES INITIALLY RAISED BY
THE CA THE SPONSORS APPRECIATE
THE PRODUCTIVE DISCUSSIONS WE
HAVE HAD. AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY- DANNY CANNOT
BECAUSE OUR ON BEHALF OF THE CO
SPONSOR OF THE BILL PUBLIC
COUNCIL. OF THE WORLD'S LARGEST
PRO BONO PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
FIRM. OUR INTENT TODAY WAS TO
BRING A TENANT HERE TO- EITHER
CALL IN OR SPEAK IN PERSON.
ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR AIMS TO
ADDRESS UNFORTUNATELY. THIS
WOMAN IS UNABLE TO SHARE HER
STORY FIRST HAND DIRECTLY WITH
YOU FOR FEAR OF FURTHER
HARASSMENT BY HER LANDLORD. WILL
CALL HER MISS GONZALEZ THIS PAST
YEAR PUBLIC COUNCIL WORKED WITH
MS GONZALEZ THROUGH ITS
HOMELESSNESS PREVENTION PROJECT
A SINGLE MOTHER LIVING WITH HER
FOSTER DAUGHTER. SHE HAS BEEN
EXPERIENCING RELENTLESS
HARASSMENT FROM HER LANDLORD
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC. WE
SHOULD BEGIN TO STRUGGLE TO PAY
HER RENT DUE TO PANDEMIC RELATED
ECONOMIC DISTRESS. LINDLAR BEGAN
SHOWING UP AT HER HOME. BOTH IN
ON AT NIGHT AND ON THE WEEKENDS
DEMANDING RENT MULTIPLE TIMES
PER WEEK AND HOUNDING MISS
GONZALEZ TO PAY. ONCE A RENT
RELIEF APPLICATION BECAME
AVAILABLE MISS GONZALEZ
IMMEDIATELY APPLIED. BUT THIS
DID NOT SATISFY THE DEMANDS OF
THE LANDLORD WHO CONTINUE TO
HARASS MISS GONZALEZ BY SHOWING
UP IN PERSON MULTIPLE TIMES PER
WEEK. AGAIN AT NIGHT AND ON
WEEKENDS TO DEMAND UPDATES ON
THE APPLICATION STATUS.
ULTIMATELY THE LANDLORD RECEIVED
SEVERAL MONTHS WORTH OF PAYMENTS
THROUGH THE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM IN BOTH LANDLORD AND
MISS GONZALEZ THEN SUBMITTED N
ADDITIONAL FUNDING REQUEST IN
TWNTY TWENTY ONE. DESPITE BEING
FULLY AWARE THAT MISS GONZALEZ
HAD FILL UP A FILLED OUT THE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING APPLICATION
THE LANDLORD FILED AN UNLAWFUL
DETAINER AGAINST MISS GONZALEZ.
LYING ON THEIR COVER SHEET IN AN
ATTEMPT TO OBTAIN A SUMMONS.
FORTUNATELY THE CASE WAS
RECENTLY DISMISSED AFTER OUT
BECAUSE YOU BY PUBLIC COUNCIL.
BUT IT IS CASES SUCH AS THIS AS
WELL AS THOSE WHICH DO NOT HAVE
SUCH OUTCOMES THE UNDERSCORE THE
NEED FOR THE PROTECTIONS IN SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION WE URGE
AND I FELT. THANK YOU MR MERMAN
AND MISCONDUCT HEISER. AT NOW
LET'S BEGIN WITH OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT HERE IN THE ROOM.
SEEN NO OTHER WITNESSES IN A
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM WE WILL MOVE
TO WITNESSES TESTIFYING VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF IT SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THAT IS ZERO. AGAIN IT IS
ONE AND THEN THREE OF YOUR
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
SUSIE AND- I'LL SKI I'M CALLING
FROM THAT THAT IT LEGAL SERVICES
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AT THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE
HAVE NOT FOR THIS IMPORTANT TO
YOU AT THIS TIME. GREAT THANK
YOU HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WHO WILL NOT FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR FROM
ANY OPPOSITION. THAT WE HAVE
AMBER MADISON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
WHO WILL BE TESTIFYING IN PERSON
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS MY NAME IS AMBER
MEDICINE FROM THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION AND I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE
INTENT OF THIS BILL. WHICH IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT TENANTS ARE NOT
HARASSED WHEN TRYING TO COLLECT
PAST DUE RENT. WELL WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS. ARE
WE STILL HAVE OPPOSITION TO THE
FORM AND SUBSTANCE TO THE
EXISTING. EXISTING VERSION OF S.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR FOR TWO
REASONS. FIRST THE ROSENTHAL ACT
PLAINLY STATES ITS PURPOSE IS TO
GOVERN THE BANKING AND CREDIT
SYSTEM. AND FOR DECADES
CALIFORNIA COURTS HAVE HELD.
THAT RENT IS NOT A CONSUMER DEBT
. UNLIKE A CREDIT CARD RENT IS
OWED IN ADVANCE OF THE SERVICES
PROVIDED. IN OTHER WORDS RENTAL
HOUSING IS NOT PROVIDED ON
CREDIT DISTINCT FROM MORTGAGE
RIGHT WHICH THERE IS A CREDIT
TRANSACTION INVOLVED. S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR WOULD NOW
SAY THAT RENTAL DEBT IS PROVIDED
ON CREDIT. THE ISSUE OF CONSUMER
DEBT IS COMPLICATED BECAUSE THE
ROSENTHAL ACT INCORPORATES
FEDERAL DEBT COLLECTION LAWS. SO
BY LUMPING SOMETHING THAT IS NOT
A CREDIT TRANSACTION INTO THAT
SUBSTANTIVE AREA OF STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW. SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR NECESSARILY APPLIES
PROVISIONS OF FEDERAL LAW THERE
INCONGRUENT WITH OUR LANDLORD
TENANT LAW. THAT BRINGS ME TO MY
SECOND POINT. THE BILL CREATES A
CONFLICT WITH EXISTING UNLAWFUL
DETAINER LAW THAT COULD MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR LANDLORDS TO
PROPERLY FILE AN UNLAWFUL
DETAINER ACTION WHILE COMPLYING
WITH THE BILL'S PROVISIONS. FOR
EXAMPLE STATED EARLIER SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR
INCORPORATES THE RULES REGARDING
THE FEDERAL FAIR DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES ACT. A FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES SPECIFIC ACTIONS
REGARDING THE FIRST CONTACT THE
DEBT COLLECTOR MAKES WITH THE
DEBTOR. THEN REQUIRES A SPECIFIC
WRITTEN NOTICE CONFIRMING THAT
DEBT. AND FINALLY MAKES A
DISTINCT DEBT RESOLUTION PROCESS
BETWEEN THE TWO PARTIES
APPLICABLE. THE UNLAWFUL
DETAINER PROCESS THAT WE ALREADY
HAVE ALREADY BEGINS WITH A
NOTICE TO PAY RUN A QUICK.
NOTICES ARE ALWAYS ARE ALSO USED
TO END OF TENANCY OR TO CHANGE
TERMS AND ELISE SO PLAYING THESE
NEW FEDERAL RULES ON TOP OF THE
EXISTING. CALIFORNIA RULES WOULD
EFFECTIVELY REWRITE CALIFORNIA'S
LANDLORD TENANT NOTICE PROCESS.
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING UNLAWFUL
DETAINER PROCESSES ARE TOO
COMPLICATED AND IS COMPLICATED
IN PART BECAUSE THERE'S TWO
THINGS THAT ISSUE. ONE IS PAST
DUE RENT THE SECOND IS
POSSESSION OF PROMISES. RIGHT
NOW SB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR DOES
NOT APPRECIATE AND TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THAT LANDLORDS MUST ALSO
GAINED POSSESSION OF THE
PREMISES IN ADDITION TO
COLLECTING PAST DUE RENT. AND WE
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE OFFER TO ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU MISTER MADISON.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM.CENA WE
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TESTIFYING BE THE
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR WE WILL BEGIN. THANK
YOU FOR OPPOSITION FOR SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS THE ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR S. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR
IN OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING-
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CREAM
GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NOTEBOOK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE WILL GO
TO LINE TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BENCHER MEMBERS BACKGROUND WITH
THEIR AND RENEGOTIATES
REPRESENTING THE SEVEN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION VERSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOW VOTE TO LINE
ELEVEN. DANIEL GOOD CARE THE
ONLY HALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA
APOLOGIES RESTING SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER ACTIVITY THANK YOU THANK
YOU. I'M IN THANKS TO ALL THE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES NOW
WILL BE IN THE DISCUSSION WITH
MEMBERS MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR DOLLY THEN- WESO AND
CAPITAL. SO THANK YOU THE
MANAGER DO YOU DO YOU THINK
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO I KNOW THIS IS
GOING TO JUDICIARY AFTER THIS
HEARING AND YOU KNOW LOOK.I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYBODY THAT
DOESN'T. I AGREE THAT PEOPLE
SHOULDN'T BE HARASSED OR- CALL
IN THE MIDDLE THE NIGHT AND ALL
THOSE THINGS BUT ALSO. AS OF
SOME WHO OWNS YOU KNOW THESE
APARTMENTS OR OR IS RUNNING OUT
ALSO NEEDS THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE. A SOME- ACTIONS
AND THAT THE STUFF THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP BY- DEPARTMENT SO SHE
CAN CAN YOU ADDRESS WHAT YOU
THINK WHAT THE OUTCOME WILL BE A
FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD ARE YOU
LOOKING TO TAKE SEVEN MINUTES TO
MAKE THAT- THE SCENARIOS THAT HE
BROUGHT FORTH THE- THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF THE
BILL- TO WHERE WE CAN MAYBE
MITIGATE THAT. WELL AT AS YOU
SAID- THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE.
WE ADDRESSED- HAVE TO DO WITH
THE PURVIEW OF THIS- COMMITTEE-
AND THE POTENTIAL CONFLICTS
EXIST BETWEEN THE- TENNESSEE
LINE THIS BILL. OUT WE HOPE TO.
ENGAGE WITH THOSE CONCERNS AND
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. TO
CONTACT BETWEEN OUR STATE LAW ON
THE FEDERAL LAW- YOU'RE GONNA
TRY TO WORK THOSE OUT IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE. WELL WITH
REGARDS TO THE TENDENCY ISSUES.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GONNA WE
BELIEVE THAT THAT BELONGS IN THE
PURVIEW OF THE JUDICIARY AND
THAT'S WHAT WE HOPE TO TAKE IT
UP. THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WE HAVE SENATOR WESSEL. THANK YOU- I FOUND I FOUND THE
TESTIMONY OF THE- GENTLEMAN IN
OPPOSITION PRETTY COMPELLING IN
THE AREA THAT REGARD THAT DEALS
WITH- TENDENCY IN POSSESSION OF
A RESOURCE SO WHEN SOMEBODY IS
ACTUALLY AN- OCCUPYING. YOUR
RESOURCE- THAT THIS WITH THIS
THIS PROVISION WOULD APPLY. AS
AS HE EXPLAINED THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN CREDIT THAT AND ACTUALLY
SERVICE SERVICES- WHICH THIS
WOULD BE- GENERALLY IS HAVE YOU
CONTEMPLATED RIGHT I THINK RIGHT
NOW- THERE'S ALSO VERY
COMPELLING ARGUMENTS. THAT THERE
IS AN OVERWHELMING NEED RIGHT
NOW TO DEAL WITH THIS. AND IN
ONE WAY OR ANOTHER I'D LIKE TO
EXTEND THE PROTECTIONS OF
HARASSMENT. OF PREVENTING
HARASSMENT OF ANY DEBTOR IN
ALMOST ANY CIRCUMSTANCE BECAUSE
I THINK THAT'S THIRD THERE ARE
THE PROPER AVENUES TO COLLECT
DEBTS WITHOUT HAVING TO. HARASS
PEOPLE AND I THINK GENERALLY
THAT THAT IN THE BILL NEEDS TO I
MEAN YOU NEED TO WORK IT OUT.
BUT I THINK THERE'S GOT TO BE
EITHER SOME KIND OF- MAYBE A
SUNSET ON THE PROVISIONS HAVING
TO DEAL WITH- WITH THE RENT
COLLECTION- BECAUSE OF THE COVER
CRISIS BUT GOING FORWARD I THINK
THERE'S STILL NEEDS TO BE SOME
SOME OVER WHAT SHE NUMBER A LOT
RELATED TO HARASSMENT AND MAKING
SURE THAT THAT IS NOT ALLOWED IN
ANY CASE- I DON'T KNOW. TO WHAT
EXTENT THAT'S SOMETHING YOU'RE-
WILLING TO WORK ON IN THIS BILL
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD. AND YOU
KNOW I COULD DEFINITELY SEND.
OUR SUGGESTIONS IN TERMS OF WHAT
WE THINK IS FAIR AS WELL BUT-
ARE YOU NOT HELP YOU CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BECAUSE I THINK
PROVISIONS UNTIL HARASSMENT ARE
VERY REAL AND SERIOUS AND NEED
TO BE. PUT IN PLACE PLACE THE
PROTECTIONS AGAINST SO THANK YOU
. THANK YOU SENATOR RESTAURANT
ACCESS AND ARE AVAILABLE AND
THEN SENATOR PORTANTINO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR- SO I
WANT IT- AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES- THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT- THAT TENANTS. NEED TO BE
PROTECTED AND SOME OF THE
ACTIONS- WHICH HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING FOR YEARS- NEED TO BE
. SOME PROTECTIONS NEED TO BE
ENACTED SO HERE'S THE PROBLEM
AND I SAID ON JUDICIARY SO I'M
STRUGGLING WITH THIS BECAUSE-
IT'S A REAL SERIOUS ISSUE IS
THAT- IS THAT CONSUMER DEBTS
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA BY TWO BY
TWO THINGS ONE WHICH IS A
ROSENTHAL. FAIR DEBT COLLECTION
PRACTICES PRACTICES ACTS ACT
WHICH WE- WROTE SPECIFICALLY TO
INCLUDE ALL THE FEDERAL.
PROVISIONS IN THE FAIR DEBT
COLLECTION PRACTICES ACT. AND SO
WE DID IT BY REFERENCE AND THEN
IT BRINGS IN FEDERAL LAW WHICH
WE HAVE NO ABILITY TO CONTROL-
IF. NOT NOW I CAN'T SAY. THAT I
KNOW WHAT ALL THE PROTECTIONS
ARE IN THE FEDERAL LAW AND
WHETHER THEY THEIR DUPLICATIVE
OF THE STATE LAW WITH SOME
ADDITIONS- BUT BUT THE STATE LAW
. IS IF WE ADDED THE STATE LAW
AND THEN THE FEDERAL AYE HAS
SOME REQUIREMENTS THAT THAT
CONFLICT WITH OUR LANDLORD
TENANT LAW I JUST THINK IT IT
BECOMES A MESS BECAUSE OUR
LANDLORD TENANT LAW HAS BEEN
CAREFULLY CRAFTED OVER THE YEARS
IT. IT IS NOT PERFECT THERE ARE
ALL KINDS OF ABUSES ON BOTH
SIDES OF YOU KNOW WITH TENANTS
THAT DON'T RESPECT THE PROPERTY
IN AND MESS IT UP AND- LANDLORDS
IT A BUTTE TAKE TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THE FACT THAT. WE HAVE A
VACANCY RATE IN MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES UP THAT'S VERY LOW
SO THAT YOU CAN GET RID OF
SOMEBODY AND FIND SOMEBODY RIGHT
AWAY BECAUSE THERE'S SUCH A
NEED- BUT BUT THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED. BY BOTH THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION- AND THE
REALTORS IS ISRAEL- LANDLORDS
ARE HAVE VERY SPECIFIC
OBLIGATIONS. AND YOU HAVE TO DOT
YOUR I'S AND CROSS YOUR KEYS AND
IF YOU. S. UP THEN YOU GOT TO%
START ALL OVER AGAIN AND I KNOW
THIS BECAUSE- AS A AS AN
ATTORNEY REPRESENTING POOR
PEOPLE I USED THE LAW
SUCCESSFULLY TO KEEP PEOPLE IN
PLACES ARE TO GIVE THEM TIME TO
BE ABLE TO MOVE. BECAUSE YOU GOT
TO GET RIGHT AND SO I'M WORRIED
ABOUT THE IMPACT OF- I'M WORRIED
ABOUT HOW THIS AMISH'S TOGETHER
BECAUSE IT'S GOT TO WORK FOR
BOTH THE LANDLORD AND THE
TENANT. SO THAT THEY BOTH KNOW.
WHAT THE RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
AND HOW. AND AND WHAT HAPPENS TO
THE PROPERTY WHICH IS SEPARATE
FROM. YOU OWE ME MONEY AND NOW
YOU GOT TO PAY ME- SO I AM- I AM
I AM NOT. I'M LISTENING I GUESS
IS WHAT I'M I'M I'M GONNA SAY I
WANT TO SUPPORT THIS BUT I THINK
THAT THAT'S A REAL SERIOUS- FLAW
IN THE IN THE IN THE WAY IT'S
SET UP RIGHT NOW AND I GET IT
THAT THERE'S ANOTHER HEARING
BUT- BUT I. HAVEN'T HEARD THAT
THERE'S SOME SOLUTIONS RIGHT
NOW. AND THAT HAS ME HAS ME
WORRIED THE BOTTOM LINE. THANK
YOU CENTER CABALLERO NEXT DID
pCENTER THAT ALSO- MAYBE I'LL
JUST LEAVE IT OKAY SO. SENATOR
PORTANTINO FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. I JUST WAS GOING TO
SAY. THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD YOU KNOW.
HOW MANY TIMES WE SAID THE
PANDEMIC HAS HAS EXACERBATED
SOMETHING WE KNEW BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND MADE THE SITUATION
INTO A MUCH MORE ACUTE AND
URGENT- YOU KNOW TENANTS NEED
PROTECTION THE SYSTEM NEEDS TO
WORK BOTH FOR THE LANDLORDS AND
THE TENANTS- THERE'S ALSO A
REASON WHY WE DOUBLE REFER A
BILL. AND THIS IS A AN EXAMPLE
OF THAT YOU KNOW WE GET TO DEAL
WITH SOME OF IT IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND THEN JUDICIARY-
WILL DEAL WITH THE OTHER ISSUES
I THINK SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
AND ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED ARE
ARE REAL- AND- AS MY COLLEAGUE.
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW THE FEDERAL
IMPLICATIONS. YOU KNOW DO NEED
TO BE WORKED OUT THIS BILL NOT
ONLY GOES TO TRADITION ALSO WILL
GO TO APPROACH. SO THERE'S GOING
TO BE HERE TO MORE OPPORTUNITIES
TO WORK WIH THE OPPOSITION TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT SOME OF THOSE
NUANCES OF OBVIOUS I'M TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY IT'S
IMPORTANT WORK. BE DONE BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
ON THE BILL AS IT MOVES THROUGH
THE NEXT TO COMMITTEES. THANK
YOU SENATOR PORTANTINO SENATOR
BRADFORD THING ABOUT INSURANCE I
DON'T. WANT TO BE REDUNDANT BUT
MY CONCERNS ARE I'VE- ARE THOSE
THAT ARE VERY BEEN EXPRESSED BY
MY COLLEAGUES AND- AGAIN- I
THINK AS- SIR PORTANTINO STATED
THESE PROBLEMS EXISTED PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC BUT THEY'VE JUST
BEEN EXACERBATED AND I'VE
LEARNED DURING THIS PERIOD THE
NUMBER OF MY FRIENDS. WERE NOT
LARGE CONGLOMERATES AND LARGE
CORPORATIONS AS WELL AS ON MY
COLLEAGUES FOR LANDLORDS WHO
HAVE SUFFERED FROM NOT BEING
ABLE TO COLLECT GRATZ BUT AT THE
SAME TIME DESIRES OF KEEPING
FOLKS HOUSE IN THEM ORANGE OF
THAT SO ON I WILL BE VOTING FOR
THIS TODAY BUT I AGAIN I THINK
THERE'S SOME LEGITIMATE CONCERNS
THAT HAS BEEN EXPRESSED-
COMPARING. RENT WITH CREDIT THAT
YOU KNOW. WHEN YOU'RE IN
POSSESSION OF A PIECE OF
PROPERTY VERSUS. CREDIT ON YOU
KNOW ON FUTURE PAYMENTS AS YOU
STATED- RAIN IS DUE IN ADVANCE
VERSUS. YOU KNOW ON YOUR CREDIT
YOU PAY AFTER YOU'VE- YOU KNOW
OBLIGATED YOURSELF TO A CERTAIN
AMOUNT SO- IT'S AN ARRESTING NEW
ONES THAT WE FIND OURSELVES HERE
HAVE TO GO WHAT BUT- I THINK
IT'S WORK IN PROGRESS THANK YOU
. THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD ANY
OTHER COMMENT. AND SO I WILL SAY
M. YOU KNOW THANK YOU SENATOR
DRAW SO I AM APPRECIATIVE OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE STARTED-
YOU KNOW BETWEEN THE OPPOSITION
AND SUPPORTERS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSE- I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE HEARING FROM REALLY THE
GOOD THE GREAT MAJORITY OF FOLKS
IS. THAT THAT THAT THERE IS. A
TRYING TO FIND AN UNDERSTANDING
BETWEEN FEDERAL ISSUES AND STATE
ISSUES BUT ALSO BUT WITH THE
ADDED CAVIAR OUT THAT WAY- DATA
FOR. A MORTGAGE IS DIFFERENT
BECAUSE SOMEONE'S NOT IN THE
POSSESSION OF WHAT YOU ARE.
READING SO I A THINK THAT THAT'S
ONE ELEMENT THAT WE HOPE THE
CONVERSATIONS TO CONTINUE BUT I
ALSO REALLY WANT TO SAY THAT- AT
AS THE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE I
UNEQUIVOCALLY BELIEVE THAT IF
YOU HAVE A DEBT FOR MORTGAGE.
OBVERSES A DEBT FOR RENTERS YOU
SHOULD BE GIVEN THE SAME
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS- BUT
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE DATA
DEFINITION IT'S GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT AND MAY INVOLVE.
ADDITIONAL CONSIDERATIONS- I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL-
AND- I. HOPE THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS I DO CONTINUE I
THINK THAT IT'S GONNA BE REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE FIND A WAY. TO
EXTEND THE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
FOR THE RENTERS- BUT ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT- IT THERE ARE
THERE IS A SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
DYNAMIC THAT IS PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION. WHICH IS THAT THE
RENTERS ARE LIVING IN THE
PROPERTY OF SOMEBODY ELSE- AND
THAT'S THE PIECE. OF RIGHT
THAT'S PRETTY MEANINGFUL IN AND
HOW WE THINK ABOUT THE DEBT. US
SO SEEING NO FURTHER COMMENTS
CENTER LASSEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. SURE MAYBE WITH SOME OF
THE TECHNICAL- ISSUES AS FAR AS
THE FEDERAL AND THE STATE COULD
YOU. REMEMBER RESPOND TO THAT
AND THEN I'LL AND THEN I WILL.
ENSURE THAT OUR GUESTS UP VERY
BRIEFLY. THE ONE OF THE-
AMENDMENTS TAKEN TODAY. ARE
EXPLICITLY ADDRESSES THE
QUESTION OF. WHETHER OUR- THAT
RENTAL THAT IS A FOR OF CONSUMER
CREDIT TRENDS. AND IT DEFINES IT
NOT TO BE. SO NUMBER ONE OF
WHAT- THIS MEDICINE WAS
DESCRIBING I THINK IS ADDRESSED
BY THAT I MEAN WILL THE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO TALK ABOUT IT
BE BEEN IN CONVERSATION WILL
CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT IT. THE
UP WE NEED TO HAVE TO SIT DOWN
AND REALLY WORK THROUGH EXACTLY
WHAT IN OF THE DEBT COLLECTION
PROCESS ON ONE SIDE THE UNLAWFUL
DETAINER PROCESS ON THE OTHER-SIDE MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S NO
CONFLICT BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM
I THINK IT WILL BE ABLE TO
PRESENT. TO WORK THAT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU EVERYBODY
AND I APPRECIATE THAT YOUR
STARTING POINT WAS. ALL AGREE
THAT WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING TO
GIVE PROTECTIONS TO RENTERS OF
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE DEBT
ITSELF FORGIVING OR COUNSELING
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT THIS IS
ABOUT WHAT PRACTICES. ARE USED.
BUT TO TRY TO COLLECT THAT DEBT
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS WHAT KIND OF
PRACTICES YOU KNOW. MAKE SURE
THEY'RE NOT ABUSIVE PRACTICES-
TO PRESSURE SOMEONE uPAY
THAT'S REALLY DIFFERENT FROM THE
DEBT ITSELF NOT TRYING TO CANCEL
THE DEBT NOT TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THE DEBT IS JUST HOW DO YOU DEAL
AS A LANDLORD WITH THAT TENANT
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS IS
ALL ABOUT. AND I LIKE YOU YOU
KNOW THINK ABOUT THE CONSUMER
WHO TAKES ON EXCESSIVE DEBT TO
PURCHASE LUXURY GOODS HAS LEGAL
PROTECTIONS I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT A RENTER YOU KNOW HAS THE
SAME KINDS OF PROTECTIONS WHEN
IT COMES TO THE PRACTICES OF
TRYING TO GET PRESSURE YOU TO
PAY THAT DEBT- SO WITH THAT-
AGAIN I KNOW WORLD. WE ALL HAVE
THE SAME GOAL ANDWE ALL HAVE
THE SENSE OF UNFAIRNESS- WE WANT
TO KEEP FAMILIES IN THEIR HOMES
WE DON'T WANT THEM TO GET PUSHED
OUT OF ILLEGALLY BECAUSE OF THE
PRACTICES THAT WERE USED BECAUSE
OF ITS THAT WERE CLOSED- SO WITH
THAT I- RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE AND I DO COMMIT. US
SUCH AS- MR BERMAN SAID WE WILL
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
TENDENCY IN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER DRESSED SO
WE HAVE A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL BY SENATOR BRADFORD AT CAN
BE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMENDED AND RE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. MON HI MON AYE BUT
CHAU ABOUT. NOT A TOWBOAT NOT
VOTING BRADFORD BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO CABALLERO I DALLY DALY
NO BROSSEAU RASO HI WHAT'S SO
WHAT'S SO I MEN. PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I. THE BILL HAS SIX
VOTES THE BILL HAS SIX VOTES AND
ONE NO WILL PUT THAT BILL ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND
WITH. THANK YOU CENTER THE
RUSSELL AND WITH THAT OUR LAST
BILL IS- FROM SENATOR BRADFORD
IS SENATOR YOU MAY PRESENT THE
BILL FROM THERE ARE GOING TO PUT
IN WHICHEVER YOU'D LIKE. I
THINK. A LOT. SENATOR KERRY SAYS
YOU LOOK BETTER AT THE PODIUM.
OTHER OKAY. GOOD FOOD IF
POSSIBLE HAVE A. BOB .ORG. I
LIKE G. OTHER ANOTHER SHE LIKE
IN THE MORNING OH MY GOSH ALL.
OKAY BIGGEST ANYWHERE THIS IS A
WEDNESDAY MORNING EVERYONE IN
THIS CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
WERE READY AND ENERGIZED TO GO
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR- SB
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT WOULD
REMOVE. OFFENSES INVOLVING
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES FROM THE
LIST OF CRIMES REQUIRING
AUTOMATIC LICENSE THE NILE UNDER
ESCROW LAWS. MINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION- THIS
CHANGE WOULD BALLOTS CONSUMER
PROTECTION WOULD CALIFORNIA'S
GOAL TO ALLOW FORMER OFFENDERS
TO ACHIEVE MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT
. OF THOSE SEVENTEEN THE NOT
ALONE SORRY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE THE
DEPARTMENT RECEIVED TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED AND FORTY EIGHT ESCROW
EMPLOYMENT APPLICATIONS OF
THAT'S- ODD AND THEY DENIED
SEVENTEEN DUE TO APPLICATIONS
PRIOR CRIMINAL HISTORY OF THOSE
SEVENTEEN SEVEN APPLICANTS. WERE
DENIED DUE TO CRIMINAL HISTORIES
RELATED TO A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE WHILE I KNOW THIS IS A
SMALL NUMBER THE LIST OF PRIOR
CLAIMS- PRIOR CRIMES I SHOULD
SAY IN ESCROW STATUTE IS OUT OF
STEP WITH THE CURRENT PUBLIC
POLICY OF ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS
WITH DRUG OFFENSES TO PURSUE.
AND GAMING FOR EMPLOYMENT- THE
HARDSHIP OF THE PAST TWO YEARS
HAVE IMPACTED VULNERABLE
POPULATION POPULATIONS
ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES WHEN A PERSON LEAVES
A CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND IS
UNABLE TO FIND. STEADY WORK OUR
IMPROPER SUPPORT THAT PERSON IS
MORE LIKELY TO. RE OFFEND RESET
OF IT AND- IN THE WIND ABOUT
CONSIST OF. ALL THIS BILL
WILSON- GIVE THE DEPARTMENT
OPTION TO FULLY EVALUATE- OUR
APPLICATION INSTEAD OF
AUTOMATICALLY THE NINE IT WHEN A
PERSON HAS A DRUG RELATED
OFFENSE. I THIS DOES NOT MEAN
THAT EVERYONE WITH A DUG
OFFENSE TO APPLIES FOR ESCROW
LICENSE WILL BE GRANTED SO IT
JUST GIVES AGAIN THE
DEPARTMENT'S DISCRETION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD AT WE
HAVE NO REGISTERED SUPPORT- BUT
DO WE HAVE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SCENE NINE
I WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES ARE TESTIFYING VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU PART OF S. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AGAIN
THAT IS ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR S.
B. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT. AND
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME GREAT THANK
YOU MODERATOR FOR LETTING US
KNOW NEXT AT I GUESS SO WE ALSO
AND- AND NEXT WE'LL MOVE ON TO
OUT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE
DON'T HAVE ANY REGISTERED
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL HOWEVER.
LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
REGISTERED OR ANY OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. CNN WE
WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES WANTING
TO TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
ANY WITNESSES. ON THE
TELECONFERENCE WHITNEY. HOPING
TO TESTIFY- IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT MODERATOR
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
OF S. B. THIRTEEN FORTY EIGHT.
AND MEDICARE WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
BRING THIS BACK AT TWO ANY
QUESTIONS OR DISCUSSION. RUBIO
WE HAVE A MOTION BY US SENATOR
GOVERNOR TO MOVE THE BILL. AND
SENILE. AND WITH A CENTER DOLLY
FORGET US COULD ON ON- WHEN WE
WERE WHEN WE WERE LOOKING AT.
PROPOSITION FORTY SEVEN AND YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THAT WAS PAINTED
AS- YOU KNOW SOMEBODY WHO HAD
BEEN. IN POSSESSION OF MARIJUANA
AND OUR LAWS OF CLEARLY CHANGING
THE PUBLIC PERCEPTION OF
MARIJUANA'S COMPLETELY CHANGED
AND- IN MOST CALIFORNIANS LIVES.
SO IS THIS BILL- WHAT WHAT KIND
OF DRUG OFFENSE WHAT WHAT WHAT
SUBSTANCE ARE TYPICALLY I'M JUST
LOOKING FOR MORE INFORMATION ON
LIKE THE BACKGROUND OF WHAT I
MEAN ALL OF US WANT SOMEBODY WHO
HAS BEEN. CHANGED THEIR LIFE FOR
MOVING FOR LIFE TO BE FREE OF
THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY- BUT SOME
OF THOSE ARE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
TO COULD YOU COULD JUST MAYBE
GOING TO LET ME TELL THE JUST IS
JUST WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT WE
HAVE CHANGED OUR SOCIETY AS OUR
VIEWS TOWARD MARIJUANA AND MOST
OF THOSE. OFFENSES ARE MARIJUANA
RELATED NOT TO SAY IT MIGHT NOT
CAPTURE THE OLD B. O. A TO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BUT THE REAL
FOCUS IS ON THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE
BEING DENIED SIMPLY BECAUSE- OF
PAST USE WITH A CANNABIS AND NOW
WE LIKE TO SAY OUR VIEWS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND OUR LAWS AS
RELATES TO THAT. HAVE CHANGED SO
INDIVIDUALS SHOULD BE DENIED
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES BECAUSE
OF THAT SO DOES THE BOARD KNOW
WHAT THE FENCE WITH EIGHT WHEN
THE KIDS ARE ACTUALLY YOUR AT
THIS BILL THE WAY I. UNDERSTAND
IT IT ALLOWS YOU TO THE BORDER
LOOK AT IT AND WHAT I LIKE SO IF
IT SAY IF WE SPENT ALL OR- OR
YOUR METHAMPHETAMINE OR SOME
LIKE THAT DO THEY HAVE THE
ABILITY THEN TO SAY YES OR NO
YEAH. THEY COULD USE THAT
DISCRETION SAID NOW THIS IS YOU
KNOW. YOU'RE OKAY REALLY WHAT
THIS BILL GIVES THE BOARD IS
THAT DISCRETION SET UP AUTOMATIC. REJECTION AS IT IS TODAY. SO
ONLY SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY
THAT THANKS TO COMMONSENSE.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SEE NOW
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS AS
SENATOR BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR COVER YET- THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CONSULTANT WILL YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WELL KNOWN AYE MON AYE
OCHO ABOUT. BUT CHAU BUG EYED
BRADFORD HI BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I DALY.
DALY HI BROSSEAU RASO HI WHAT'S
UP WHAT'S SO I MEN. PORTANTINO.
MAN FIVE PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
. NINE ZERO. THE BILL HAS NINE
AYE VOTES SO THAT IS OUT- OF
GERMANY THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
WE WILL NOW LIFT THE CALL- ON
ANY OF THE OTHER BILLS THIS WAS
OUR FINAL BILL- IF CONSULTANT WE
PLEASE- CALL THE ROLL ON.
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY MEN. MAN
I GREAT THAT. SEVEN ONE. SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR- OF THAT A
COMMITTEE WITH THAT THIRTEEN I'M
SORRY WITH SEVEN VOTES IN FAVOR
AND ONE IN OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT
SO WITH THAT- THAT CONCLUDES OUR
UP HEARING ON BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS.